the winter olympics in beijing are
looming ever closer and china is being
put to the test as it battles to contain
outbreaks of the highly contagious
omicron strain of kobit 19.
china has adopted a zero covet policy
that means strict restrictions in public
life in many parts of the country so is
it working or might it backfire on to
the point we ask olympic struggle can
china beat omicron
[Music]
[Music]
well thanks very much for joining us
here today on the show and in the studio
with me is tsuji fanbrunnisom from dw's
asia desk she says a zero covid policy
might have benefited china in the last
two years but omicron and the olympics
could be a game changer
also with us is tobias court a professor
of public health at berlin charity
hospital he argues nothing can stop
omicron it can only be slowed down
and warm welcome too to science
journalist kai kupferschmidt he says
with much of the country vaccinated the
question of what an exit from zero
covert in china could and should look
like looms large
thank you for being here all three of
you thank you for those interesting
comments lots to talk about so let's get
on with it uh suji the eyes of the world
uh on beijing that's for sure the stakes
are high
what is your feeling is a large scale
outbreak of the omicron variant likely
in china
in the near future
i think because of the high transmission
rate of omicron it's something very new
china is dealing with at the moment
and i think china will do everything in
its power to try and contain and not
lead to an outbreak during the olympics
as well as we kind of have a perfect
storm situation because we have the
lunar chinese lunar new year that is on
the 1st of february which is usually the
period of the highest migration in china
and even though the chinese government
has advised everyone to stay at home and
not travel and they are taking a lot of
precautions for the olympics they're
fencing off
all facilities and athletes are being
varied to the campus and having every
day a test
and if you're vaccinated you don't need
to quarantine but
all the precautions are in place but i
think with every single omicron case
that arrives in china
every single case will
weaken xi jinping's zero covet policy
and
i think that
in the future we can as you said before
we can only uh slow down our micron but
i think china will um stick as uh
with the zero covet policy for as long
as it can okay uh kai cooper schmidt i
just wonder you know a lot of people
must be listening to this kind of these
kind of comments looking at the
situation at the moment and wondering
why on earth is is an event like the
olympics being staged at all at this
time in this place
it's a good question um i think i mean
of course from the chinese perspective i
think it's also um it's it's an
opportunity to prove to the world you
know the superiority of of the chinese
approach to
two stars cov2
um
i i do think we are in this phase of the
pandemic now where these questions about
what can how much can we go back to
normal life what are the things that we
you know that we can do and can we do
them safely is is an important question
and i've always been a little bit
skeptical of um you know risk mitigation
being basically avoiding all risk right
i mean the question is how do you stage
an event like the like like the beijing
olympics and how do you try to do it in
the safest way possible
um
i mean the bigger question that that i
have really is
how long can a country keep the zero
covert strategy up and i think it's not
completely clear at the moment because
there are some questions about omicron
how much more transmissible is it really
than delta we don't really know that we
know it's much better at infecting
people who have some immunity but that
doesn't mean that the virus itself is
more transmissible necessarily and so
you know
i think what we've learned in this
pandemic again and again is that
politicians policymakers need to be very
flexible they need to look at the data
they need to be able to
to navigate a constantly changing
environment and i think
what you just said that china is going
to hold on to this policy as long as
possible i think that in itself is a bit
of a danger because really you want to
be flexible you want to be nimble you
want to act fast and and also give up
these policies when it becomes clear
that they are causing more hurt than
than than they're actually contributing
to the public health in in a country
like china and i think those are the big
questions for 2022 what do you have to
add professor court to those uh in terms
of hard data hard information to the to
the questions that uh kai corporation
has just been asking
so data are important we don't we don't
know the data from china i'm sure china
is collecting data like crazy but the
public doesn't know much about it so
cyril kovitch obviously uh failed
because omicron has arrived in china so
they it's more the strategy like as
little as possible until the olympics
for sure but even during these china
admitting that it has failed here
certainly not certainly not i mean the
restrictions are massive and they try
their best to really
keep it
quiet and down as much as possible but
now you need many people come to china
there will be clusters within the
athletes group journalists as we see now
with the handball european championship
no matter what measure you do and
germany i think has good had good
measures and
13 50 people infected so
that is that is not gonna work okay we
talked about it already so let's take a
closer look at china's xero covet
approach which is under pressure to put
it mildly
this is what china's zero covet strategy
looks like
even with just a few known coronavirus
cases the government is imposing strict
curfews for whole metropolises comprised
of millions of people it's an extreme
lockdown
the affected cities will be sealed off
and residents will only be allowed to
leave their homes for daily covet tests
and shopping
if that
the policy is strict but effective china
claims to have the lowest infection rate
in the world
until now
their first omicron cases were reported
in early january and authorities are
deeply concerned because china's cinovak
vaccine doesn't seem to offer much
protection against the omicron variant
the winter olympics are just around the
corner which means that tens of
thousands of foreign athletes officials
and journalists will soon be entering
the country they are supposed to enter a
strict quarantine upon arrival
separating them from the rest of the
population
but experts still wonder
will there be a massive outbreak of the
omicron variant in china
and one of those experts is tobias court
and i'd just like to come back to that
question do you think they can keep a
lid on this how concrete can you be
about that not for long i think the
omicron
variant has shown to be so transmissible
in other countries and that will also
happen in china you can slow it down but
i don't think you can you can really
stop it down well
these are the most strict measures that
we can think of right now and i agree
with kaiku fishman that it's it's hardly
imaginable that you can keep this for
for months
to to really keep it down it won't be
possible so at one point i expect to see
a raising cases in china yeah
kai what do we what do we know about
omicron and what do we need to know
i think one thing that sometimes gets a
little bit lost it we just saw it in the
clip um you know that
that the vaccines don't seem to offer a
lot of protection against nomicron i
think was the phrase
you really have to look closely at what
what that means is protection from
infection um we do think that the
basically all the vaccines that we have
at the moment do offer significant
protection from severe disease and from
death
and that's really really important
because
while the virus spreading like wildfire
through china would still be a huge
issue in terms of
disruption to work and all of these
things the hope is that it wouldn't lead
to the kind of wave of deaths that we've
seen in other countries earlier and so i
think it is important to realize that
you know we're talking a lot now about
the potential risk for china in 2022 but
they are in an enviable position in some
ways i mean they have managed to weather
this pandemic a lot better than a lot of
other countries have they have avoided
these big waves and whatever happens now
they are not looking at the kind of
death wave that we've seen in spain in
italy in the u.s in the uk
and but you need to be able to also
shift from that strategy at some point
because otherwise you can really be
creating a lot of hurt in in those
moments where you're clinging on to a
policy that maybe at that point isn't
really
creating a lot of hurt
well i mean if you imagine that omicron
starts spreading and the only answer
that the government has is to lock down
more and more places for longer and
longer um then
those are those are huge side effects
that you're basically
um you know willing to to to have the
public suffer in order to keep the virus
from spreading but at some point of
course the risk of this virus spreading
might actually be lower at least the
risk in terms of public health the
political risk is of course a different
one and that just like we're seeing in
the uk at the moment with boris johnson
lifting all restrictions
i think you know whenever you look
around the world you have to look at the
politics in these countries um you know
within the country to understand a
little bit why certain decisions are
being made it's not just the scientific
evidence as we all know
suji what do you know what can you tell
us i know it's quite i know it's
difficult but what can you tell us about
how the uh
the chinese people are responding to all
this uncertainty about what sort of
knowledge they have at their disposal
what how the government is sort of
working with them how
whether the the government's priority is
the people or the games these are very
difficult questions
i think uh in general
most chinese people do support the
government's decision to keep a
zero-covered strategy
and i think
china has in accordance with its
knowledge of its health system
it set up a
covert policies which will suit its
health care system and currently uh most
hospitals in china for example in
shanghaied
we haven't even seen many cases of
omicron but the hospital is already
burdened with too many uh patients and
so
the main priority currently of the zero
covet strategy is china knows uh that
its hospitals nationwide will not have
the capacity at the moment um if
the coronavirus uh were to
um have waves as we had here in europe
so but the current vaccine that china is
using simply won't work against the
against the new variant so the and it
but but it has to work the chinese the
chinese government have got a really big
problem there
well potentially yes uh so as kaikou
fishman said like they
we expect not that many severe cases but
if you have many people getting infected
then if the likelihood is lower that you
get severely infected still a lot of
people will get severely infected
vaccinated or not so it's it's
one has to stay flexible really one has
to stay more
watch the situation more dynamically and
then act so just just having one
strategy for as long as possible is is
very difficult to communicate and and i
also think that the suffering of the
population in terms of public health
consequences outside of the viral
infection will be severe in china
how much of a threat is this to the
credibility of xi jinping as chinese
leader
i think that um china can withhold for
example if there's a an outbreak i think
for one month of quarantine
we can predict that china and the
population will be able to
deal with it for one month but you know
if it carries on and the virus spreads
and then we have entire cities and ports
in lockdown of more than six months or
leading up to six months people will
definitely get frustrated and people
will lose their jobs
and companies
global supply chains will be hit
and i think
of course the xi jinping government also
wants to
keep people uh happy with the government
and they know that anything beyond one
month of lockdown will definitely get
people very uh frustrated at towards the
central government
as a journalist where do you
where do you see that situation leading
you've got the the problem with lockdown
the the threat to the economy you've got
the public health threat how's that
going to be knitted together or how is
it going to
impact china in a in a in a in a drastic
way potentially yeah i mean i do think
that this year at some point we are
going to see a massive impact on china
whether it is because of you know the
public health restrictions that are put
in place in order to to keep omicron
from trading or because omicron spreads
i think
at least in the future when we look back
i feel like a lot will depend on how
well china is preparing for plan b i
mean given
the very clear risk that omicron is
going to spread the question is
what are people doing what is the
government doing to prepare for that
eventuality what do we know there
i
i honestly couldn't say i i haven't been
following enough what
what's being said in china i think at
the moment all that i'm hearing is still
we are you know committed to the zero
covet policy but i think it would be
ludicrous if people weren't in the
background you know gaming out okay what
can we do if this really spreads how do
we keep the disruption low how do we
make sure hospitals are staffed how do
we make sure if there is a big influx of
patients with severe disease how do we
deal with that that is really what
what people are going to judge the
chinese government's um you know actions
in 2022 on i think
and what what do you think uh uh to
tobias about what what does this tell us
about sort of other similar events in
the in the in the future like bundesliga
football matches in germany or the
carnival in rio or all these large-scale
events that are so important for
humanity
well i think we need to understand what
is actually happening collecting data
meaningfully and not just
comparing cases
to nothing so i think we really need to
be flexible you cannot compare a
strategy in one country and bring it to
another country in that work so we in
germany have to decide what is what is
our measure where we say okay go how
many infections or how many severe
infections after a soccer game football
game we accept so that's something we
need to discuss but like keeping
everything away from the people for a
long time won't work
okay
the omicron variant is spreading at a
pretty much unprecedented rate at the
same time though people in some places
at least some countries at least are
again out enjoying packed bars and
packed streets how does that work indeed
does it work let's have a quick look
the omicron variant is giving
researchers reasons to be both concerned
and hopeful
they're worried because the virus is
much more contagious than its
predecessors
they're hopeful because it also appears
to be less severe by comparison
germany's leading virologist predicts
that the disease will become a
controllable endemic rather than a
prolonged pandemic
we already expect that we will reach
this endemic state or virtually reach it
by the end of the year
he says the prerequisite for this is
vaccinating and boosting the elderly and
other at-risk communities
that's already the case in israel where
the government has lifted nearly all
coronavirus restrictions despite an
increase in infection numbers
life on the streets appears to be
getting back to normal
in spain people wear masks voluntarily
large parades like this one as well as
restaurant visits are all possible
without restrictions
just how dangerous is omicron
that's the that is the big question kai
cup fishmate i mean we see people out on
the streets in that report in israel and
uh and uh spain for example
and here in germany at the same time my
sense is that we we're standing on the
cusp of a possible
or very large-scale crisis in the next
two or three weeks that is what we're
being told
i think it's very important to to kind
of paint a very differentiated picture
about what the risks are here we have in
the last two years talked a lot about
you know these catastrophic risks of you
know lots of people dying we have seen
more than 100 thousand people die in
germany of covet 19.
that is not what we're seeing that that
is not what most scientists are worried
about if we look at at the next few
months
most of the worry is that we still have
a lot of unvaccinated people in germany
compared to spain for instance compared
to israel so that means that we do have
you know the risk of some people having
severe disease and death but
the majority of people are vaccinated
they are protected from severe disease
and death but they might be sick they
might have to isolate a lot of people
might have to quarantine because they've
been in contact is that already
happening in your in your circle here in
germany because that people are talking
about that um yes a lot now yes it's
very clear to me that that the we are at
the beginning of this very very steep
rise of cases that we've seen in other
places because we had measures in place
for delta that was delayed in germany
but we are now seeing the same kind of
rise that we've seen in places like
denmark or spain so everybody's going to
experience this in their circle they're
going to see a lot of people get sick
and isolate
but it's not the same worries that we
used to have and i think that is very
important now endemic doesn't come from
the word end right endemic just means
this is a virus that is here to stay but
most people who get infected with it
already have some kind of immune memory
of having been exposed to the spike
protein ideally through a vaccine or
through natural infection and so
the the the societal implications are
different ones but there are still
societal implications like we said with
china if everybody is sick of work that
disrupts supply chains in germany if a
lot of doctors are out sick from the
hospitals you still have a problem with
having having enough people there for
all the other diseases that people have
that aren't covet and so we have to take
this seriously but we also have to
realize that there is this is a
different level of worry i think than
what we were worried about the last two
years and that's thanks to the vaccines
and frankly
the biggest thing we can still do is to
make sure that the people who haven't
had a single shot of this vaccine get
one and that goes for germany but it
certainly also goes for three billion
people worldwide who haven't received a
single shot of this vaccine sure so gee
how concerned are you personally
uh personally uh if i'm being very
honest uh i have a family in china
elderly relatives and i think personally
i feel more comfortable for some reason
whether it's rational or not
that they are in china with a
zero-covered policy at the moment than
if they were here in europe and when i
think about my relatives saying oh i'll
come visit you in europe i'll say
no it's better not to come also my other
families in new zealand which is also
zero covert strategy and i feel
a level of comfort for whatever reason
you know that they are in a zero covert
strategy country
but in saying that i have so much more
freedom and i can travel in the summer
and when the cases are down
i can come in here to the office you
know it's a
so i have a level of freedom that they
are not enjoying for example and i can
still go abroad within europe and even
other countries
so yeah
professor kurt what's the uh what what's
the the worst case scenario for germany
in the next in the next couple of months
for you
it's um the worst case scenario is that
we're getting more severe uh sickness
than we think we're getting so that that
that would be something where we're
adding on uh the the issue with the
current pain people are not able to work
and we're getting more and more patients
in the hospital so it's actually already
starting that that um physicians and
nurses are are not as
as available as before because of their
incurrency in order their catering
currently
so so and if this is is increasing then
the question is can we keep the system
running
and if then
severe cases come which we do not expect
to happen because of the vaccination
because of what kaiko pushmi explained
then we are running into a real issue
but i i don't expect that to happen and
what can we learn from countries like
israel and spain where there's a
definitely a different approach it's
always very difficult to compare
countries so in israel the elderly
population are vaccinated so as a
country the vaccination rate is lower
than in germany but the the higher risk
of high-risk population those are
vaccinated so i think that's an
important consequence that we may think
also to conduct in germany
omicron is an opportunity
that's a that's a phrase that i've heard
a couple of times
i said i see you sort of looking so
slightly boosted an opportunity for one
i mean um
you know this is still
a deadly
how often i have heard that phrase or
very similar phrases in in in the last
couple of weeks psychologically it's
understandable that i mean we have had
two years of really bad news and a lot
of times with this virus it felt like
the worst case scenario came true now
omicron is
falls a little bit outside of that scope
because it is actually from what we know
a little bit milder in the disease it
causes than say delta not necessarily
milder than the virus it evolved from
which is important
we don't know what the next variant will
be but i mean
i i think people focus a lot on the
virus and they say omicron is an
opportunity but we are in the situation
that we are in because we developed
vaccines in record time and we
vaccinated a lot of people around the
world in record time
that is why we are talking about
transitioning to some kind of endemic
state it is not because this virus
itself is somehow you know that harmless
it simply isn't it's the fact that it is
meeting a population that has a huge
amount at this point of of immunity and
in a lot of countries that's
vaccine-induced immunity and it's
infection-induced immunity on top of
that which is why a country like the uk
probably has a you know very high
immunity wall to a virus like this okay
you mentioned earlier uh german
virologist christian rosten he is very
influential here in the country
he says he believes we will get back to
the kind of life we had before the
pandemic
do you share that optimism yes of course
i don't think this pandemic i mean a
pandemic always ends
the question is how much death and
destruction do you get along the way and
you know the vaccines were our way of
reducing that that burden it doesn't
necessarily cut the time short that it
takes for for this pandemic to work its
way into an endemic state but it reduces
the price that we pay for it and that's
why we want everybody to be vaccinated
and and
the sooner we get to that stage i think
the sooner we do get back to normal life
i do think there are some things that
will stay for a while longer i do
imagine that even next year or the year
after we might in winter have certain
restrictions like wearing masks things
like that but i also think that that is
a burden that we can all easily you know
shoulder after the last years of uh of
restrictions that we've lived through
suji how do you see the future here in
germany for yourself do you share that
optimism
um i think that i can
say optimism um and opportunity for
europe and the rest of the world means i
think not so much optimism for china
china actually um economy grew in china
in the during the pandemic and now it's
declining in the last quarter so i think
while the world now is dealing with
omicron in an open way uh china might
question its zero strategy okay we'll
have to leave it there we've been
talking about china and uh omicron i
hope we've given you plenty of thought
if we have do come back next time until
then bye bye and cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you